i uh
my tour bus um is a piece of [ __ ] rv
like oh yeah
you know you know what i wanted to buy
the one from stripes
that gmc made with the six wheels i
always wanted to redo one of those and
there's one that's the the it's the palm
desert package or something and it's
like two total ron burgundy it's that
[ __ ] 70s green with the floral like
captain's chairs and a green shag rug
and i was just thinking man
if i ever [ __ ] redid one of those put
a humidor in there with some cigars and
[ __ ] moving cigar lounge oh my god oh my
god mobile cigar lounge yeah sick i know
but then you gotta watch because then
then all your demons
are just right there
yeah yeah that's another thing too i
learned that's when my drinking got out
of control was when i brought it home to
the house
and then i could oh there's a i don't
have to go out too bar cause before like
i always had it under control because i
had to go out you know if i felt like
getting a drink but i was at home and i
was watching a game
in your sweatpants it's like dude i
don't want to [ __ ] take a shower and
[ __ ] go out and do all of that [ __ ]
so then you just wouldn't drink and then
it wouldn't get a hold of you but when i
had it at home yeah i had this thing
where um part of conspiracy theory you
know you get massively overwhelmed and
depressed when you're reading that [ __ ]
um
so how i i then i after i got out of the
conspiracy theory [ __ ] i went the other
way and i started watching like me tv
and all these old [ __ ]
shows from when i was a kid and
everybody on those shows drank and
smoked so i would just sit there they
were drinking i was just i was drinking
with like ephram zimblis jr like every
[ __ ] night watching 77 sunset strip
and uh and you know it was started off
with this then it became that
then my wife started getting on me like
jesus christ through the signs and i
started i go it's a home poor
you go out to a bar they take out the
eye droplet it's just like that's not a
[ __ ] drink
and then i remember one night i came i
told this story before i came down the
stairs because she goes don't have
another one when you have three you
start snoring like your dog here so
i was like all right all right and then
i was like i just have two i can just
have two right and then i was just like
you know there's still you know eight
minutes left in the show pour another
one so i poured the other one it was
over and i was walking down the stairs
to our bedroom and i didn't know if she
was still up or not i literally was
hiding it
on the side of my leg
trying to make sure the ice cube wasn't
gonna clink against the side of the
glass and i was just like i am like this
close away from having a bottle on the
back of the toilet let me let me just
step away from this [ __ ] so
um i'm not like an alcoholic you know
what i mean but i do think that
addiction is like is more of a spectrum
than you either are you aren't and i
think that if you're a habit guy like me
no different than sugar and salt like i
never craved mcdonald's unless i was in
a jam and i ate it and then for like the
next three days like i see the golden
arches everywhere like dude i'm gonna
get a [ __ ] another double
cheeseburger man so
yeah i smoked a cigar and then i was
like man are these bad for you then i
looked up i was like how many cigars did
george burns smoke a day and it was like
10 to 15 i'm like great i can do two a
day you know it's like it's so easy
there's no way
there's no way he smoked 10 to 15 a day
why google told me that i don't know i
know and if you know who put that
information out there a cigar smoker
that's trying to get his wife off his
back
he smoked 15 a day christ i'm a
lightweight
i'm only smoking seven
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]